[Music]
welcome back to cbs saturday morning a
parent's guidance can be essential to
surviving in this world and that's true
in the animal kingdom as well but in
northern california some unfortunate sea
otters were literally adrift until a
very special program program stepped in
to help jonathan vigliotti has the story
these sea otters at the monterey bay
aquarium are more than just the star
attraction oh yeah they're very curious
this morning
the curious bunch also plays a key role
in nursing pups separated from their
biological mothers in the turbulent
pacific ocean
most pups would not survive if not for
the aquarium's intervention and here on
the west coast where the species is
threatened kevin connor with the
aquarium says saving every otter pup is
critical when we bring in a pup that has
been stranded when it's ready to be with
a mom we pair them with one of these
exhibit sea otters
after a health check by an aquarium
veterinarian their new mothers go to
work what is their specific function
here at the rehab center their natural
instincts equip them to be a better mom
than any human being could ever be so
they they help raise the pup
they'll only spend about a year being
rehabbed they're surrogates familiar
with humans will stay at the aquarium
and be matched with new pups
so these exhibit otters essentially
prepare
rehabbed otters
to be reintroduced yes yes they prepare
them for life in the wild over half of
the population growth that we saw in
that 20-year period is actually because
of the sea otters that we rescued and
then released back into this area
30 miles north where just fuji patrols
as part of the aquarium's restoration
project the growing number of sea otters
is a sign of success but here we are and
we've seen a number now of sea otters
it's almost hard to believe
that they're threatened here in elkhorn
slough there's about 100 to 150 sea
otters in elkhorn slough weren't always
this densely populated in the early
2000s there's probably only about 20 sea
otters in here beyond elkhorn slough the
southern sea otter whose habitat
stretches from oregon to mexico is still
recovering from the deadly fur trade
that reduced their population from 16
000 to only 50 by the early 1900s today
there are an estimated three thousand
sea otters so their presence in
estuaries and kelp forests plays a very
important role in keeping those habitats
healthy fuji's research here isn't just
about saving otters the species is
critical in protecting carbon absorbing
sea grass
she'll dive to the bottom grab some
crabs bring them back to the surface and
eat them as well as share with her pups
eating those crabs is helping protect
the sea grass here exactly by keeping
the crab population under control
they're helping other species like sea
slugs
help keep the sea grass healthy our
oceans play a critical role removing
carbon from earth's atmosphere about 25
percent and studies have shown seagrass
alone sequesters about 10 percent of
what the ocean absorbs i mean when we
talk about trees and their impact in
absorbing co2
the same is certainly true for seagrass
as well they're very similar
yeah so seagrass is known as a blue
carbon they're able to sequester that
carbon and put it into the sediment
that's under the sea floor and that
plays a really significant role in terms
of you know global carbon sequestration
that makes sea otters a key puzzle piece
in the fight against climate change and
that's kind of where the otter
is an ally we've some people around here
call the otter a fuzzy climate warrior
because just by being out there they
help to keep these ecosystems healthy
the monterey bay aquarium's sea otter
recovery program is expanding just fuji
is hoping to replicate the results of
elkhorn slough in moro bay an estuary
100 miles south
four sea otters have been released so
far looking forward we're working with
partners to really see is it possible
to
re-establish sea otters in areas where
they're no longer present but they were
in the past so a success here but still
a lot more work to do yeah a lot more
work to do but we're very hopeful that
we'll see a lot of benefits for cbs
saturday morning i'm jonathan vigliotti
in monterey
so did you know jeff that you and sea
otters have something in common what's
that constantly carrying snacks
yes i like the snacks are good
and i like the way how they like you
know then he put up his dukes there yeah
in the beginning but like it's funny how
they yeah they have little pockets
underneath their yeah isn't that cool
just to store the food yeah they can
just get it right outside i like that a
fuzzy climate warrior they are just darn
cute to me